- I am really excited to be here today
as we continue to evolve our
special operations forces,
because I really wanna hear
the thoughts and questions
that this distinguished group
of both thought leaders and practitioners
and those just in the
general public that we serve,
although student general public, I guess,
the academic general
public that we serve, have.
So I'm gonna try to leave
time for questions at the end
and then happy to talk to folks
in the intervening moments, in the breaks,
in the breakout sessions,
as that's useful.
As we think about SOF's
role in the 2022 NDS,
I wanna start sort of towards
the end of that document,
where I don't think a lot of people start,
which is in the force planning section.
And I'll read you the quote,
but it says, the joint force
must be shaped to ensure
the ability to respond to
small-scale, short-duration crises
without substantially impacting
high-end war fighting readiness.
And the reason I start there
is because that shaping
is really to us, about the continued use
and the potential growth of
our special operations forces.
When you think about
what history shows us,
when we are designing our
military for high-end conflict,
at the end of the day,
attrition based warfare does not fare well
in small scale contingencies and crises.
And so that is what is in SOF's DNA,
SOF was designed in World
War II to fill that niche
and then has grown since then
and evolved its capabilities.
So it's part of our heritage,
it's part of our skillset.
We have five core missions
as we think about them,
in the sort of broader terms.
One is contributing to
war fighting advantage,
one is campaigning, then
there are the three Cs,
counter VEO, crisis
response, and counter WMD.
Those last three are what I would put
in part of what the NDS terms,
other persistent threats.
SOF will continue to use its expertise
to handle those kinds of threats,
so that the larger joint force
can do the first part of the NDS,
to prioritize modernizing and meeting
the pacing challenge of the PRC
and dealing with the
acute threat of Russia.
So when you add campaigning
into CBO, CR, as we say CM WMD,
you realize that a
fundamental role for SOF,
is actually also part of
the underpinning of the NDS,
and that is preventing
strategic distraction.
And I really think
that's an important point
for everyone to think about.
When you think about the last 20 years,
when we became such experts in CT and CBO,
because we're so good at crisis response.
But that still meant that
the larger enterprise
really focused on that mission set
and pulled us away from some
of the evolutions that we saw
as the PRC develops with its technology,
as we saw Russia becoming
increasingly aggressive.
So with that understanding
and also I would say,
with the understanding
that we do all of that,
today at less than 2%,
approximately 1.7% of DODs budget.
So to me, that is exactly
what we're talking about
when we say we need to have the ability
to handle those small scale contingencies
and respond to those
short duration crises,
without diverting the larger joint force.
The joint force can only
modernize if we are successful
in preventing those
strategic distractions.
So that underpinning is there.
If we then look at, what we
do in the three core NDS,
directed means, how are we going to win
this decisive decade?
I wanna talk a little
bit about each of those.
Integrated deterrence, campaigning,
building enduring advantage.
Those are our three lines
of effort under the NDS.
If you think about integrated deterrence,
it is again, something that is
I think second nature to SOF.
We build high functioning,
cross-functional teams
all the time.
They are interagency most of the time,
they involve foreign partners.
And what we do with
that is we try to create
strategic impact with tactical excellence,
but we also provide that platform
and that convening ability.
That's something that carries
into integrated deterrence,
that is gonna give us options
and give our national
decision makers options
in this next decade.
We also don't just convene,
but we enable our interagency
partners in many cases
and our foreign partners.
One really interesting example of an area
where we're trying to increase capability
and where we think there's a lot of room,
is if you think about what I'll call,
irregular warfare medicine.
And IW medicine is about making sure
that in remote hard to reach areas,
there's medical capability.
That creates resiliency
for a civilian population,
but also for a military
that may not be as capable,
makes them more willing to fight
if they believe they have access to care
and it's particularly
urgent and acute care.
So that's a good example of
where we can enable our partners
by just training them in a
very specific enabler as well.
And then, as you all know,
the lead up to that is we
provide some of that enabling,
usually in sort of as they're learning.
Another example of how we
bring everything together
and perform high functioning
cross-functional teams,
is a term I think many of
you're probably familiar with,
which is the triad concept.
And that is something that USASAC,
our Army Special Forces folks,
have come to come up with primarily.
But it applies to everybody,
which is the cyberspace SOF triad.
And the reason that's interesting is,
not because it's actually,
a really different way for SOF to operate.
It has more to do with the fact
that people don't think
of those things together.
They think they're all
distinctly different, right?
Like we're supposed to be in the desert
where there is no electricity.
So why would we be talking
about cyber and space, right?
How's that supposed to work?
And it's really because of
our placement and access.
So our placement and access
can enable cyber and space operations.
So we allow us to go to a,
we take existing capabilities,
bring them together,
and then make them more
than the sum of their parts,
because again, of our tactical excellence
in placement and access.
If you think about campaigning,
this is a place where I would say,
we're going a little
bit back to SOF's roots,
in irregular warfare and
unconventional warfare.
We traditionally have,
helped shape the operating environment.
We provide indicators and
warning for the joint force
and that is also feeding into
integrated deterrents as well.
We create dilemmas for adversaries.
And this is a really interesting place,
where I think in some ways
the sky is the limit for SOF,
because we are tailorable, scalable,
because we can do things
at a smaller level.
Our ability to essentially
make mischief globally,
to make our adversaries have to look left
when they wanna be staring
right, is infinite.
It's really a matter of how
much we are willing to do
and where we're willing to do it.
But our adversaries are looking globally.
They're not just looking
at the INDOPACOM AOR.
And so it's really important
that we be creating dilemmas
for them both globally and in INDOPACOM.
And that's something that SOF
is uniquely positioned to do.
And that also flows a little
bit into the indicators
and warning because we're able
to then get to another thing,
which is help counter
coercion and influence.
By being present,
we make it harder for our
adversaries to win the day.
I would say what we see big
picture, is most in the world,
don't wanna have to make
a choice and that's okay.
But what we don't want them
to do is choose the PRC way.
We don't want them to give
the PRC unlimited access,
unlimited rights.
We want them to feel like they
have to at a minimum balance.
Where possible, we want
that balance to shift to us.
And by being present, in some
cases it doesn't take much,
because there is sort of a traditional,
the Bellator initiative, things like that,
that increasingly other countries see,
through kind of both the
cost and the benefits, right?
When you build roads and buildings
that are made with shoddy concrete
and they fall down three years later,
maybe you should have just waited,
what would probably be
the full three years
for the US government to approve
any sort of project, right?
I mean that's the dilemma.
But what most countries do,
and it's the logical choice,
for what I would call a
weaker state strategy,
is they try to get
something from both of us,
'cuz that's what they need.
They need a lot, you know,
they see themselves as needing a lot
and they'll take from both
and they'd rather not have to choose.
And again, as long as we are
there on the playing field,
making sure we understand
when that balance
would shift to our detriment,
then we can keep that
in balance at a minimum
and over time hopefully
get to our advantage.
But that only happens if you're present
and only SOF can be present
in numbers globally.
We are in 80 countries today.
So our ability to see that coercion,
to see the influence and
to adjust that balance,
we are the force that's
doing that, without big mass,
without creating huge, new
dilemmas for our host countries
and potential partners.
The other thing that we do
that I would say is very
traditional is in our mission sets
of increasing partner
resilience, resistance forces,
special reconnaissance,
and partner adaptability.
Like those are all classic
missions that we've had
from our founding
and they're ones that
we're returning to now.
When we then look at enduring advantage,
I think that's where you see a
really exciting time for SOF,
because when I talk about kind of using
some of what we already know how to do,
going back to our roots,
it's about the balancing act.
And the second piece of that
is investing in our future
and investing in the now
and how we rebalance.
And a big piece of that
is us starting to develop
and align with our,
a joint concept for operating
that builds on service
specific capabilities
and really highlights those,
but still brings them together.
And I say that because
I think most of you know
that over the last two decades,
most SOF, regardless of their service,
we're doing fundamentally
the same mission.
That's no longer the case.
We need undersea to be undersea.
We need people in the
air to be in the air.
We even now are starting to
have SOF aligned space operators
and we are like, the
whole spectrum is there,
and we need people to be
aligned to their service.
And that again, tactical excellence,
has to be at the highest
level proficiency,
so that we can create new effects.
It is not about doing the same mission
and we have to build as an institution,
some institutional things that
we didn't really have before.
And it's tricky I would say,
and I think those of you who are operators
can speak to this, but when
you're doing sort of this,
a huge number of reps and
sets on the same mission,
passing tactical knowledge to
the next unit is fairly easy.
You know, this unit comes off the field,
here's what we learned,
here's the new state of play,
off to the next unit handoff.
And it keeps getting better
and better and better.
When you're doing a wide
array of different missions
in different domains and
bringing multi-domainS together,
that learning process has
to become more systemic.
It has to become more
institutionalized and thoughtful
and it still has to somehow be easy.
And that's probably the
hardest part of this.
And so we are looking at
really interesting technologies
to try to help us with
machine learning and AI
and how to enable the human even more,
because we have to do it,
not just for the tactical excellence,
but so that operationally we are learning
in these different spaces,
when there might be a gap of a year
between when you run one kind
of operation to the next,
or maybe two years, we
might have to do five other
different types of operations in between.
And the same force will be asked to do
very different things, and
that's hard, obviously.
I mean, tactical proficiency
partly comes from practice.
And so that's gonna be a balancing act,
as we move into this new timeframe,
where we have a really
unique array of missions
we think that we're
gonna be presented with,
because again, we're
scalable, we're tailorable,
we can do something that
gives our national leadership
options that they would
not otherwise have.
And we can create dilemmas,
that might otherwise be obvious,
who the creator of that dilemma is.
And that's a goal of ours
every time we can do it.
So we are doing this in different ways.
One way that we're trying to
strengthen the institution is,
we are really focusing on something
that the deputy secretary
is very eager for us to do,
which is really build our
analytics and decision tools.
And that sounds really boring and wonky
and I know that it kind
of is, but it's vital.
I mean AI, machine learning
don't get you're much
if you're learning, you
know, how to tie your shoe
and you already knew how to do that,
like that's not really helpful.
We need to learn how to do the things
that we don't do well today
or learn where we thought we
were good and it turns out
we weren't having the
impact we thought we were.
So it's both about metrics and analytics
in improving our decision tools.
We are investing a lot in
defendable, repeatable analytics
and decision tools now
as a SOF enterprise.
And that's an exciting
place with war gaming,
bringing SOF into the
big service war games
and many of you are
familiar with, I think,
the challenge that we face,
which is most war gaming
starts at phase three.
So if our entire strategy rests
on a concept of deterring,
which means we didn't
have the conflict right?
Once we're at stage three,
we're in the conflict,
where we have to prevail.
We kind of lost,
we've failed in most of
our strategy at that point.
Our goal is obviously to
win in the prevent piece,
but when it comes to prevail,
you only prevail if you've created
some asymmetric advantages going in.
And that's where SOF can help.
That's where we can create, again,
not just dilemmas, but now
advantages for our side.
The joint force needs some of these
key asymmetric advantages
and SOF is positioned
to build those building blocks
that will give them that.
But it's not gonna be
easy and it's challenging
as the entire national security
community and apparatus
grapples with what does it mean,
to intentionally compete and
try to avoid the conflict?
How much do we devote
to those lines of effort
and what is the shape of that?
That's an entire inter-agency effort.
It's an entire national
effort to be honest.
And I think we're still finding
our way a little bit there.
And so that is one of our challenges,
because for SOF to plug in, you know,
we plug in, kind of again,
in phases sort of zero
to two, if you will.
Once the shooting starts we have a roll,
and history is shown again,
no war goes off without SOF
ending up having to go in
and create some of those key
advantages, key intelligence,
key strategic moments.
But our focus is really on
everything that happens before
and building that into the
war games that we're doing
is also pushing the joint
force to think more seriously
about what beyond presence
and a credible military force option
they bring to the table in prevent.
And it's again,
it's a challenge.
So the other thing is as
we look at innovation,
and Bill's gonna talk about
this a lot more than I need to,
so I won't go too far in it,
but there's some really
exciting innovation,
besides AI and machine learning,
and kind of how we use data and you know,
we have a lot of things the
commander likes to talk about
all of our nexts, we have ISR next,
we have next gen mobility,
I think there's a few more next gen,
we have a lot of nexts and that
again just reflects the fact
that we all see that where we are today
is not where we have to be.
This is the decisive decade.
So we have to invest
smartly across the spectrum
and probably the area that I personally,
am most interested in
and am pushing us out,
but that we're all doing it
together as an enterprise,
is the cognitive domain.
I think there is so much
work we can do there.
As we think about this whole spectrum
of the cognitive domain,
it's both about what we do
to enhance our performance
as the elite performers.
You know, we're sort of,
we think of SOF almost as as your elite,
you know, pro-athlete.
How do you enhance that performance
by using the cognitive domain,
but then how do you apply
that and how do you disable,
dismantle, decrement the
adversary's performance?
How do you get in the
adversary's decision loop?
That's classic, you
know, OODA loop theory,
that's not rocket science,
but it's a new enemy.
How are we looking at that adversary
and understanding their
decision processes?
If you look around academia today,
I would say there's at
least 20 different theories
of the case for how the PRC
likes to make decisions.
Which one's right? I don't know.
But I am worried that we as an enterprise
have not been able to model
or really simulate enough of those options
to start to refine our understanding
of the dynamic that we have to be at,
where we test and we come back
and see what did they
do, what didn't they do?
We're still very early in those phases
and I think that is a
real challenge for us.
So again,
I'll let Bill talk more about
the specifics in innovation,
but it is an exciting area where I think,
we believe we can enable
our humans and, you know,
from the top to the bottom, I
think the one thing I can say
about the SOF community and enterprise,
is we all believe the
human is far more important
than the hardware or the enabling tech.
It's about the innovative use of that,
that that human puts that to,
or the how you enable that
human to be more effective.
But science is really moving rapidly
and if we can harness that and focus it,
I think we have tremendous opportunities.
So again, I'll just go
back to where I started,
which is we are evolving
once again as SOF,
to meet the nation's challenges.
I think it starts with
our tactical excellence
leading to strategic impact.
And the first step in that
for us, is that underpinning to the NDS,
which is preventing the
strategic distraction,
so the joint force can modernize,
so that they can mobilize
the way they need to.
But it's also in doing our core missions
and going back to our roots
across those three lines of
effort the NDS demands of us.
And with that I'll take questions.
- [Speaker] So for those
that want ask questions,
please raise your hand.
Also when you have mic, push
the button, it'll turn green,
you'll be able to project across the room.
Any questions that stand up?
Emma please, any questions?
Emma is one of our senior
advisor professors at Yale.
- And feel free to ask,
I mean you can ask about
anything you want about, in terms of,
how things are in DC, what
my office actually does?
Not everyone knows that.
I mean whatever questions
you have, I'm very open.
- [Audience Member] I have a question.
Thank you for your talk.
You mentioned AI,
and you mentioned AI in
the context of operations.
Forgive my ignorance but like,
how does that work?
- Yeah, so I think it comes down to,
\what we see more and more,
which is information
overload, is one piece of it.
So using AI to give you a
more digestible set of options
and then sort of assessing
some of the likelihood of those options,
'cuz there's a piece that
is war fighter experience.
But again, as we go into this new era,
where you're not gonna
have the reps and sets
on the same mission set,
it's gonna be more important
to take different data sets
and create the options and
get a sense of your, you know,
you're still gonna rely
on war fighter kind of,
the thing that isn't science, the art,
but you're also gonna be informed now,
by what the AI tells you are
some of your better options
or some of the opportunities.
It's also using the AI in much
bigger, back at, you know,
sort of headquarters
war gaming, hopefully,
to more effectively model and simulate
and see where we can get.
I think those are probably two places,
and I know Bill, probably has
some other like thoughts too.
- [Bill] Yes ma'am.
I guess two things popped into my head is,
a lot of like next generation
ISR you talked about,
you know, processing all
that data that, you know,
we're collecting from an ISR perspective
is just huge amounts of data.
So we definitely need more advanced tools
in that arena, and then.
- And then machine, and then maintenance.
- And the machine learning
part of it, yeah, and then,
you know, the other thing is,
you know, irregular warfare,
sentiment analysis, that
kind of thing, you know,
for our operators and, you
know, in foreign countries,
or you know, more hostile scenarios,
just having a better
understanding of the sentiment,
of the local population, if you will.
I think that's another example
I think where AIML tools
could be useful,
especially using, you know,
publicly available information,
cyber tools and those kind of things.
So just a couple other examples.
- Yeah and I would say like,
and the other thing is,
improving kind of our
maintenance of our fleets.
Like, there's a lot there
that we're actually,
with industry which is
advancing in that space a lot,
where your sensors, along with like your,
we have much more efficient
models now for how to use our,
even our fleets that as they get older,
we're more efficiently
employing them because of AI,
because we're able to see
specifically where they're broken
and not just rely on a
static profile of, you know,
two missions and then you
get something, or you know,
it's just not static anymore.
It's more specific to the actual aircraft
or other parts of our fleet.
So that's another kind of big area.
And then we're trying to automate,
it's not just sort of sentiment analysis,
but the whole spectrum of
intelligence that we collect,
because again, it's
overwhelming in some cases,
in some opportunities, to
the degree that we can start
to automate pieces of that as we,
particularly in areas where
we're already a little clear
about the adversary that
would actually allow us
to free up humans to do some other things,
so that you get a smaller number of humans
who have to do that exploitation
and analysis in some cases.
Yeah.
- [Sam] Good morning ma'am, Sam Hussein,
representing Peraton
Corporation from Washington.
Can you just touch a little bit more about
and tell us a little bit about
the Office of Strategic Capital,
that was just launched
recently at the Pentagon,
and how it's working out
as far as engaging in
bridging industry innovation
and bringing it to the SOF war fighters?
- I wish I could, but I cannot.
So, Bill hopefully knows more about this.
This is probably more
firmly in Bill's name. Yeah.
- The only reason I jump on that ma'am,
is 'cuz they had something called
the Trusted Capital Marketplace
a couple of years ago,
that they were working and you know,
basically what it is is a,
you know, an analysis of,
you know, venture capitalist,
you know, different capital
sources to feed small businesses
and those kind of things
that might have capability
that we need.
But definitely wanna make sure
that that funding is trusted,
you know, trying to build
that synergy between,
you know, the capital
and the small business
to what our operators need.
So that whole chain of security, you know,
is the intent of that.
So I don't think that the
Strategic Capital Office,
I haven't seen anything
huge out of that yet,
but I think it's the same intent.
That's not much of an answer.
It's a little bit nascent
but that's the same intent.
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
- [Speaker] All right, we have
time for one more question
and it's gonna come from
Ms. Amasky in the back.
- Okay.
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
Good morning and thank you for coming.
You mentioned cognitive ability.
So my question is, you know,
you come to a university like Yale,
how are you going to attract the brightest
and best students in the country
to want to pursue a
career in the military,
let alone special forces?
- So it's an interesting challenge,
because I actually think we have,
so much of what we hear
America's youth wants today
and special forces actually
has it sort of in spades,
I would say.
So when people want meaningful work,
they want a working environment where,
their boss and people care
about them as a whole person,
they want to make a difference,
they wanna be part of a team.
All of that we offer, along
with healthcare benefits,
everything that you don't
get in the private sector.
So in our world,
and we've actually like
really ramped this up even,
like NSW does this amazing thing,
where I think it's every six months now,
and it's only been about two
years you've been doing this,
but like at every echelon level,
the commander has to meet
with their formation,
every single individual, with
themselves, the chaplain,
somebody else and somebody else
present, the doc, everybody,
to literally find out how are you doing,
specifically, tell me what's
going on in your life,
how's your family, how's your
finances, how's your health?
Are you feeling okay
mentally? Are you stressed?
And then from that you
get specific referrals
to whatever will help
make your life better.
And there are no
disciplinary or professional
sort of career consequences.
That happens every six
months at each echelon,
that has to happen.
And so that investment in the person,
is something that I hear
young people craving,
somebody wanting to mentor them,
to grow them, to help
them be more effective,
to give them that support, to
have a community that cares.
So I really think our
storyline is actually great.
And then, we also in special operations,
literally tackle the
hardest problems, right?
The wicked hard problems
are what we're trying to do,
to be the best.
And so it actually I think is a little,
we struggle with I guess
the marketing of it,
because it's very clear it's
not working at this point.
But I think the story we
have to tell is fantastic.
And if we could tell it more effectively
in the spaces where young people
are talking and listening,
I think we have a real opportunity.
Now we do draw from the general force.
And I will say, I think
the other thing is,
and we're talking about this
in the Pentagon, how do we,
modify, reinvigorate, revamp,
the contracts we make, right?
So if you're in the Army
and you come into the Army,
and what you really, really love to do
is sit at your computer
and do cyber operations
and you really don't like
marching through the woods,
you have zero interest
in the outdoors, right?
I still want your cyber talent.
How do I build pathways where
you can come in and out?
Where you learn enough and understand,
you can't be a drain on the force.
But there's a lot of operations we now do,
based here in the US that
enable our forward operators.
How do we honestly admit that,
bring that into the force
successfully, and then grow that?
And so there is a challenge as
we sort of have to reimagine
some of the contracts we
make with America's youth,
because there's a piece that is absolutely
always gonna be about, you
have to be physically fit,
you have to be able to perform
in high stress environments forward.
But there is an a
growing piece of our work
that actually happens back here,
where there's still stress,
but it is very different.
You don't necessarily need
exactly the same things
that I think people think you
need for the military career
to be successful.
And can we also make it so
that you can come in and out,
three years you're in giving me your best,
then you go out for three
years, you learn from industry,
you do the things you like to do there,
but then we can bring you back.
Right now in some cases,
we have very arbitrary time limits on that
and age limits, that given
as we age as a population,
as we're healthier,
and as some of our jobs
really aren't that stressful.
You know, people wouldn't have to like,
why do we say that's the
age you can't do it anymore
for the nation?
So I do think there's a little bit of,
there's conversations about that.
That is an extremely
hard problem, I will say,
because I will also, I mean no surprise,
to produce the military that
we've produced over the years,
taking risk when you know one
thing works is really hard,
'cuz you're putting people's
lives on the line potentially.
And so, big Army is gonna
have a hard, hard, hard time
reimagining this contract.
But they know they have to.
And so they're thinking about it,
they're talking about it.
Around the margins,
they're starting to do it.
But I think that's the other piece of it.
I think we have a great story to tell,
but we also need our foundational services
to be able to tell a story
that's a little different
to America's youth, I think.
Is that it?
- [Speaker] All right,
with that, please join me
in thanking DAS E. Logan
for the presentation.
(audience applause)
(upbeat music)